le plus précieux dans la vie ça restera
toujours les gens qui sont là
aujourd'hui
y a que ça qui compte à lomé nick
torreton tu me connais pas mais ça va
pas d'arrêt qui a fait ça mais vous
souvenez de renshaw c'est son grand
frère un actuaire des forces spéciales
nous ont fait un monstre
on dirait que les fantômes de londres
nous rattrape en outre ac
shaw vit dans un monde qui ne marche pas
selon vos rêves et que ça te plaise ou
non
toi et tes amis en fait partie
maintenant c'est pas mes habits
c'est ma famille
ce coup ci il s'agira pas seulement
d'être rapide
quelqu'un pourrait m'expliquer ce qu'on
ferait exactement
y'aura vannes a besoin de temps de leur
dire qu'on croyait qu'on pouvait pas
faire mieux
on les courses et partez bête de guerre
assez armés pour rayer de la carte
on est au delà de la folie là c'est
carrément cinglé
c'est quoi le plan donne un dernier run
je suis pas en train de mater
au saguenay en
au sam est en hausse à mener